samuel l.jackson married Sabine it still
came out as written gee that was the
manag for him so every Earth Day now
Disneynature releases a annual
documentary first there was earth and
emotions and now African Cats next year
is chimpanzee I didn't see earth but I
really enjoyed that was a really really
visually stunning animal documentary and
African cats is another good one I've
always loved animals I think that a lot
of the creation on the earth is really
really pretty I'm always like how do
they do this how they how are they there
without being noticed I know they wear a
lot of camouflage and stuff but the
flukes they capture in this film is
really very remarkable this film tells
the story of various groups of cats
lions and cheetahs and the largest theme
of the movie is how a parent raises a
child in the wild and then it quite a
bit of connections with just how a human
parent would raise a human child you
know a lot of it is actually remarkably
similar and you think you know are they
just making this up because they're
writing a very nice dramatic narration
you see this stuff that they're talking
about you see these parents defending
their children against you know
predators and trying to raise them
safely and you see like sadness in the
in the creatures faces and things happen
to their young when something goes wrong
and it all just seems very very well
portrayed the way I would critique an
animal documentary is completely
different than how I would have a
regular movie the purpose of an animal
documentary is show very very amazing
footage of animals doing things that you
don't normally get to see and make it
interesting you have to have a driving
force to the story there has to be
something interesting and you have to
feel invested in what the animals lives
are going through and I felt that in
this movie samuel l.jackson did a great
job at the narration but honestly this
is a very good animal documentary I like
a little bit more and the reason is
because the colors and the creatures
that are in the ocean are of a much more
wide variety than just on the land in
Africa this one isn't as visually
stunning the cats themselves aren't is
interesting to me as underwater life but
this one is still good it's a it's a
good family film if your kids love
animals will probably enjoy seeing this
movie and believe it or not I was
getting into the stories of these
creatures that what they were trying to
do and I was amazed at how similar they
are to humans and how they try to raise
and protect their children I'm going to
give it three out of four stars and I
recommend seeing it if you'd enjoy those
kind of movies I'm tired of these monkey
fighting cats on this Monday to Friday
great plains of Africa